The Joe Rogan experience,
did anyone send you a that
grand theft auto dmt trip?
A lot of people think that
you had a big influence in it.
I'm sure there's a lot of
people done dmt besides me,
but it it,
it starts off with this guy and you're
just driving around with your father and
then he,
the kid tricks him into taking it
while he's driving so he starts
tripping out
fucking shit to you from your
crazy dad
down on the ground.
Tripping balls.
Yeah.
And then watch what happens.
This is the part where it
starts getting really agony.
This is fucking awesome shit.
It's something.
Where
does it go?
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Yeah.
He's getting inducted by aliens.
Monkeys first and then the alien
ship shoots him up into a spaceship.
This is people in near
on the same wavelength.
If they didn't hear them,
if they don't know me and know
me when they were coding this,
they need to show to you are you are
the herpes that there is no cure for it.
We are on the same wavelength.
We would get along great
if they don't know me,
we would get along great if
this wasn't inspired by me.
Definitely fucking comic people.
Everyone you have terminated all of this.
You see that he did this alien
given the fucking metal side.
Wow.
This is intense shit made
this with no underwear though,
but why are you hiding
your Dick and an asshole?
You're just flying through space to me.
Oh you shouldn't.
You shouldn't be holding onto your team.
Your fear and your insecurities.
Let the breeze flow through that left
flies this hover on your asshole flying
around in space.
What do you care?
And you're.
You're one with the universe,
so the trip and you can get high
and every time he gets it here,
inner thoughts and it's really trippy.
So like once it goes online first all as
comics or I'll just kind of hanging out
at the comedy store,
smoke weed together
and gets into the oculus rift.
I've heard that this game is the most
successful single piece of anything
anybody created over
$1,000,000,000 in three days.
Not Amazing.
It's amazing,
but there's never been anything
that's sold as well as this.
God bless America.
Right.
When you think the economy's down
cocaine or both in a day?
Yes.
It is only so much flow.
You could do.
I mean,
after the one time I was offered dmt
by buddy buddy's buddy and we're up in
Canada and he's like,
hey man,
I got this shit is dmt,
and he's like,
I'm a,
I'm a.
You heard of it?
I'm like,
I'm familiar.
I've heard of it.
I haven't.
I know some people that I've talked about
it like it's just a so why don't we go
back and we're all out
drinking and hanging out.
I'm like,
no,
he don't want to do dmt when your bank
and start shoving fucking hallucinogenic
drugs up my body with a guy that just
does not sound like a good idea and I'll
wake up glazed like a fucking krispy
kreme doughnut or fucking,
you know,
that's when somebody gets eaten.
Yeah.
That could happen too.
Especially when you're drinking now.
Usually not.
Suppose you're not even supposed to.
He was just too nonchalant about
slinging us fucking doing dmt.
I'm like,
that should be taken with a lot more
care when they give him some of that.
What's the fuck a viking?
That's what that is.
No fucking Viking
roofie them up,
but some DMT.
You're a fucking human being.